how are you sir I should I should
mention mention that this gentleman's
name is Riley
take a seat Riley
if you have a problem walking Riley you
have a problem walking
I got a [ __ ] leg you know kind of really
hi Robbie
good morning how are you I'm just fine
you are absolutely are you're absolutely
beautiful well it seems like Riley is
attracted to Rob and I can see you're
smitten right this is are my intentions
right is to attempt to save the planet
but my ulterior motive is to get girls
also people have probably accuse you
being crazy but you're not that crazy
right
well Robin is a tough one to get but
yeah isn't that amazing
the planets about to blow up but
everyone wants girls yeah well what's
you know what's the planet with our
girls do you have trouble getting women
strangely really now let's talk about
your abduction 1953 was the first
abduction you were seven years old and
you were in your parents house I assume
I saw lights above the river right three
nights running I would wake up in the
wee hours of the morning mm-hmm
on the third night strangely my brothers
who slept in just in the same room with
me I could not awaken them right I went
out me and my dog to investigate these
lights yes as we came to a clearing
mm-hmm near the river I saw the ship
okay mothership no salsa huh it was
moored to the ground by three flexible
legs and it danced like a cork on water
now why do you think they came to you do
you ever ask the aliens this it has
something to do the audience that is
this is the alien in the audience they
are the audience they rarely abduct
people at random they have a purpose it
would seem that I have a genetic trait
there's a hold up from their first
mixing with the Elohim are with man
about forty two thousand years ago in
northern Africa now let me get the story
alien genes you could possibly be able
showed us millions of other human I
believe you
Warren alien millions what you're saying
is the BRB ones came here and they they
made it millions of years ago with man
millions of years ago well forty two
thousand years ago forty two thousand
days ago on an island about a hundred
nautical miles north of what we now call
Libya I see and they made it with humans
they first made it with the when they
found that they could not get home nor
clone themselves right have you ever had
sex with one of these be ambiens and
1964 you did I bought the great
mothership at the time I was a
bare-knuckle fighter on earth hmm I
fought an alien and overcame him and I
requested a liaison with some of the
alien women are they high are they cute
they were hybrids like mixed human alien
women so they're big fans yeah they were
fine right but let me state clearly and
unequivocally that though I have set on
the forward deck of an X 6 and warp
through the hyperspace windows and came
barrel-rolling
out into the brilliance of some
primordial yesterday you had not found
anything in the cosmos that moves me
like earth women interesting there you
go Robin now you didn't really love me
you yourself might be part alien what
the blood has been diluted right as time
went along I mean what have you
obviously through the generations yeah
yeah but of course and so they I'm not
placing myself in some special right
tons of us are aliens yeah yeah we are
turns of us have the trait right are you
married no I'm not right however you're
looking for a bride my goodness I was
meant to have perhaps several rights me
too
I've yet to meet a guy who doesn't picky
supposed to have several another do it
aliens anybody with a penis anxiety but
alright let's get down to some serious
jump ahead for a second he's got some
information have you gone to the
authorities and said listen know the
authorities came to me they did what
authorities NASA NASA came to you the
Japanese the Japanese have been with you
have been with me yes they accuse you
smoking weed and stuff like that
thinking maybe you hallucinate at all
this they try to lock you up
do you ever smoke weed
[Music]
[Laughter]